[Music]
foreign
at the height of the covid-19 pandemic
many countries impose tough restrictions
to protect their populations from the
potentially deadly disease at times with
little regard to the collateral economic
and social Fallout
in this week's show we're talking about
covid-19 and human rights Welcome to our
covid-19 special
in South Africa unemployment has soared
jobless and destitute people are
everywhere on the streets of
Johannesburg crime is rampant
foreign
offer new prospects for the African
country in Cape Town scientists
succeeded in developing their own mRNA
vaccine in just one year
but first to China
since November protests have broken out
against strict lockdowns DW reporter
hang shuang Li explains why
cgp
down with the Communist Party Xi Jinping
stepped down this video which reportedly
shows protesters in Shanghai has been
watched over 2 million times online it's
been decades since so many people in
China risked repercussions by publicly
voicing their anger on the streets and
on social media
I never thought that there would be a
day where we could raise our voices like
this you're all so brave please protect
yourselves
for three years people have suppressed
their emotions now they've reached their
limit
protesters and the victims of a fire
that broke out in a room tree they're
also demanding a relaxation of covert
restrictions many locals suspect that
the lockdown measures are the reason the
ten victims couldn't escape
dignity
um these are all things that people know
from their everyday lives
when there are positive cases in a
residential building
barricades are erected and the
building's doors are blocked or locked
but even apart from that people have
come to feel that these policies have
gotten out of hand that they've become
irrational that it's no longer about
protecting lives and to some extent
achieves exactly the opposite
Beijing has been scrambling to contain
major outbreaks since the Omicron
variant emerged which led to a seemingly
never-ending cycle of lockdowns and mass
testing
public descent has continued to grow
despite censorship efforts some videos
are still circulating online like this
one about harsh lockdowns in Shanghai in
April
personal tragedies were shared online
including stories about children being
separated from their parents in
quarantine or this one from a father who
says that delays in treatment caused by
covet restrictions led to his child's
death
aside from the other problems the
lockdowns are of course a massive burden
on the economy China had originally
forecast 5.5 GDP growth for this year
but it's not likely to meet that
and these statistics aren't just numbers
there are people Behind These statistics
people who run restaurants or work in
tourism and they're all in a terrible
economic situation
zero kovid is President XI jinping's
signature policy that he has championed
personally after he secured his historic
third term China did loosen some
measures in early November but Beijing
insisted it was not a return to business
as usual China can't afford to drop all
measures that's because Beijing decided
to stick with its own less effective
covid vaccines and vaccination rates in
the most vulnerable group are relatively
low only around two-thirds of people
over 60 have had three shots
we estimate that there are about 190
million older people in China with
chronic diseases like diabetes or high
blood pressure
those are additional risk factors
China will have to address this problem
if they want to avoid an exit wave that
would result in extremely high death
tolls
Beijing has now announced a vaccination
drive for the elderly a move that could
be the first step towards lifting
pandemic controls
China has eased some covered
restrictions following the recent wave
of protests but this isn't a sign that
the authorities are completely backing
down on the contrary Beijing has vowed
to crack down on what it calls hostile
forces a warning that dissident voices
could pay a high price
[Applause]
China is not an isolated case according
to a un report covid-19 restriction
measures have violated human rights
around the world
Uganda also imposed strict lockdowns DW
reporter Julius maganwa spoke with
victims of police violence there
[Music]
shows us the scars on his body
he's accused the Kampala police of
assault
during the pandemic security officers
enforced lockdowns and restrictions on
Movement by any means necessary
I was stopped by three police officers
riding on motorcycles
they violently dragged me off my
motorcycle and started beating me up
I was wounded by a bayonet I still have
a scar my fingers were beaten and you
can still see what they did to me
[Music]
for journalists reporting on such human
rights abuses was also difficult and
even dangerous
David kalyancolo filmed security
officers enforcing the nightly curfew in
his neighborhood
he says the police later came to his
home and assaulted him outside on his
veranda
beating him until he lost consciousness
I suddenly felt a sharp pain in my head
before I lost consciousness
I regained it two days later at the
hospital
doctors told me that I almost died
according to the Uganda Human Rights
Commission such abuses Rose sharply
during the pandemic security agencies
including the local defense units or ldu
often acted arbitrarily and without
oversight the Ugandan Army says these
violations were punished the big issue
is if any lodu violated rates of the
population what was that
you saw our code society and they were
taken to military courts and they were
charged and sentenced and some of them
have to now are still serving their
sentences
by many victims including twaha kabega
were reluctant to report cases involving
the security forces
I didn't bother to report the case to
the police I just told my parents about
it and got treatment for the injuries as
you may know sometimes people report an
incident but no action is taken
in his book quarantined
Ugandan academic and cartoonist Jimmy
speyer centango recounts his own ordeal
in the Ugandan isolation Center at the
outset of the pandemic
he insists that the Ugandan State needs
to be held accountable for violations of
basic rights even during times of crisis
the cartoons which depicted injustices
and human rights violations during the
pandemic are a powerful indictment of
these abuses of power
and if we do not document such
experiences then we don't have reference
point points maybe in future when we
want to make a reflection of how to
handle them better
it's like everything easily gets
forgotten because that was a period as
if as though of Darkness where people
would freely do whatever they felt they
could do
uh when everyone was in panic
in late September Uganda declared a new
outbreak of Ebola caused by the Sudan
strain of the virus for which no vaccine
is available
once again lockdowns and quarantines are
being imposed to contain a virus
the Ugandan military says it's now
working more closely with human rights
groups to put basic rights at the
Forefront of managing the health
emergency
later on the president ordered their
training they were trained to that we
have a much much finer local defense
unit we have a thinking that if any
other challenge comes in like we are
seeing Ebola coming in all of these
agencies will come on board and we are
able to work together more harmoniously
than before
on December 2nd the last known Ebola
patient left the hospital but the
lockdown in the two high-risk districts
was extended another 21 days the
incubation period of the Ebola virus
pandemic restrictions were also imposed
in South Africa for a long time to
prevent the further spread of the
covid-19 virus
the subsequent economic downturn has
exacerbated social inequalities there
many South Africans have lost their jobs
and are now doing everything they can to
make ends meet
foreign
Steven moyo gets up at five every
morning and pounds the pavement of
Johannesburg in search of work
even if he finds it he earns 30 Euros at
most
but those good days are now few and far
between
the economic impact of the covid-19
pandemic continues to be felt here
especially in disadvantaged communities
the situation is waste nobody is coming
to hire us and I'm living water can I
get money for food in the month to pay
the rent since there's no employment
since the coffee they've gone in South
Africa
the economic decline is catastrophic in
the wake of what were some of the
strictest lockdowns in the world
an estimated 10 million people are out
of work
many have been left with nothing but the
generosity of strangers to rely on
there's no work and I've given up
looking now I try to make money by
dancing and begging covid made things
even worse
crime too is on the rise
rampant infrastructure theft is putting
even more strain on an economy that's
expected to grow by just 2.1 percent in
2022.
in Xiao Teng Province South Africa's
economic Heartland Railway Services have
nearly come to a standstill
thieves and vandals are removing tracks
and stripping Railway stations bare
in Johannesburg local authorities are
struggling to cope with the rise in
cable theft which has been leaving
residents and businesses in the dark
[Applause]
because of the number of people who are
unemployed and sitting at home with
nothing to do
theft and vandalism are increasing
we're trying very hard to keep up and
people are often left without power for
hours on end
teams like this one are working day in
and day out repairing outages caused by
cable theft
analysts are concerned that the current
economic slump could be hard to turn
around and that the coveted pandemic may
have tipped the country into a downward
spiral
since April 2020 when the lockdowns
began and covet really hit hard with one
of the highest mortality rates we saw
the amplification the acceleration of
our contradictions unemployment soaring
10 to about 45 percent you know you can
compare that to early 30s Germany which
was part of the problems that created
Nazism and then austerity and I fear
that the right-wing Tendencies when you
have these explosions rioting and
looting and xenophobic attacks these
will get even worse in the coming years
large-scale civil unrest already swept
through parts of South Africa in 2021
poverty is also at least in part to
blame for the rise in aggression and
violence against the estimated 2.9
Million immigrants who live in the
country
[Music]
gelante groups have been carrying out
checks on shops owned by foreigners
[Music]
yeah expert is 2024.
I've been making unofficial visits to
foreign-owned businesses to check for
expired goods and for owners immigration
status
yeah yeah but you're not allowed to be a
isn't it
so now that is going to be a problem
so who's got your papers
South Africa is teetering on the edge of
a social and economic precipice and the
pandemic is only partly to blame
South Africa kept extending its lockdown
period because there were too few
vaccines available in the country
to enable low and middle income
countries to produce their own vaccines
in the future the World Health
Organization is promoting the transfer
of knowledge with an mRNA Hub in Cape
Town
[Music]
how is an mRNA vaccine produced South
African scientists explain the role DNA
plays in the process to visitors from an
Indian pharmaceutical company
then how do you mix them that you are
proud
that's an exciting part the changing of
perceptions and the building of capacity
South Africa contributes to the
knowledge base that exist
and training the rest of the world and
not just a receiver this program will
allow
companies to have the capacity to
actually start to produce various
vaccines that means if there's an
outbreak next time of a of a very
different
um
of a virus or bacterial but it's a
pandemic nevertheless the companies will
have the capacity to actually respond
quickly to that pandemic because they
will have in-house capacity to produce
vaccines
the training takes place at the MRNA
vaccine Hub in Cape Town run by the
company African
in just one year scientists here
developed a candidate mRNA covet vaccine
based on publicly available data on the
moderna vaccine
the World Health Organization is
supporting the Hub to transfer this
expertise to other low and middle-income
countries
before kovid and the postcode the things
has changed people are helping each
other they want to help each other
to make the society in the better way
that's why we are here because African
is they have the technology we have the
facility we have infrastructure we can
make together
biological e is a leading vaccine
manufacturer in India it also plans to
go into mRNA vaccine production
scientist arvind Kumar Jain researched
mRNA technology at Oxford University
until 2018. then he gave that up
believing it would be at least 30 years
before the technology would be ready but
the pandemic changed all that now he's
responsible for developing an mRNA
platform for his Indian employer
once you have the technology in your
hand you know how to handle mRNA it's
very easy to switch from one vaccine to
another vaccine so obviously the first
vaccine is going to be costly for you as
of learning as of manufacturing setting
up everything but once you have it you
have it you can make vaccine of almost
anything you want
researchers have already started using
mRNA technology to produce TB Ebola and
cancer vaccines
this network has the potential to build
to to diversify the global vaccine
manufacturing landscape and I think that
is the beauty of it you cannot have
Pandemic preparedness if you have
centralized vaccine manufacturing we've
all said never again never again can you
find a continent not having access to
vaccines because it doesn't have the
ability to produce its own vaccine so
we're going to keep the momentum
some Civil Society organizations fear
there could be conflicts with big Pharma
for example over patent infringement
but not everyone is worried that this
could affect vaccine production in South
Africa
we can either license from them or we
can invent around it
and that's that's actually what Pharma
companies do because in any area
generally somebody else is doing
something in that area so they go look
at the patterns and go and see if they
can invent around them and you know some
of the patterns they're relevant because
we don't need to use that particular
process
so no I don't think it's it's going to
be an issue
the biopharmaceutical company biovac in
Cape Town has already made a technology
transfer deal with Pfizer
the state-backed company's freezer farm
with 130 refrigerators is ready
it could produce up to 100 million doses
a year
I don't think what we have seen in terms
of export bans that we've seen in other
countries Supply material shortages I
don't think that threat has gone away it
has maybe subsided because the pandemic
you know and the Infectious rate is not
that high but we haven't solved those
issues to say what will actually happen
next time countries haven't come out and
said okay I did an export bin but next
time I won't nobody has actually said
that so the threat is actually really
alive
and you know again you know
nationalistic interests are likely to
take place the next time
both biovac and aphrogen the major
partners of the MRNA Hub are urging
their government to maintain support for
the industry amid fading Global interest
in the pandemic
the U.S and the Europe of manufacturing
entities were built on on similar
structures of subsidizing and support
from government learnable income
countries are asking for exactly the
same we ask our leaders to have a
long-term strategic View and not a
short-term view so we've done analysis
in South Africa one one dollar
investment in local Manufacturing in
certain sectors and of course the
vaccine would be very high multipliers
if effectively can give 13 of economic
value back into the country through
skills development stimulating r d
direct foreign investment
as the scientists from India wrap up
their training they're optimistic about
starting to produce mRNA vaccines back
home next year
and in Cape Town the next scientists
from Senegal and Tunisia are ready and
waiting
one African country that seems to have
weathered the pandemic relatively well
is Nigeria
has been their practicing physician in
the West African country for decades
he became infected with covid-19 at work
as a medical professional he closely
observed the effects the disease had on
his body
[Music]
while checking my SVO so I noticed that
there was a daily decrease in the
saturation
as at the time we got to about 85
present oxygen saturation I had to call
from Dr okora in charge of the
Kobe Center and I told him I'm bringing
myself in for admission and during my
stay in the in the covered world I'm
aware of many people that died I had
seen worst cases although yes
my family was afraid my wife was my
mother was
the worst times when I left my bed to
have my bath or
use the toilet
is the dyspnea
what's this now breathlessness
and you understand the need for oxygen
then at this the oxygen hunger that was
assisted with kovid you would appreciate
it more in a patient who tells you I
cannot breathe as a health worker in a
third world country I believe our
government hasn't covered well after
about a week there I improved gradually
and I
was discharged
I repeated it says to cover the PCR test
on discharge about
two weeks after the first
test and I was going to clean a bit of a
clean bill of health
so I went back home
and took my daughters of my wife
[Music]
it's about covid-19
DW science reporter Derek Williams has
answered hundreds of viewer questions
this time cats about wanted to know
how do the average symptoms from Omicron
subvariant infections compare
when Omicron hit last year experts
everywhere worried about a couple of
questions first
was how infectious the new variant would
prove to be compared to its Forerunner
Delta and of course it quickly became
clear that Omicron was a lot more
infectious the second question that had
everyone holding their breaths
was whether Omicron symptoms would prove
more severe than Delta symptoms were and
and there was this kind of huge
Collective sigh of relief when the
opposite proved true
now there are of course plenty of
exceptions but in general an infection
with an Omicron subvariant is less
likely to send you to the hospital or
intensive care station than one with
Delta or or earlier versions of the
virus
the big reason why experts think is
because subvariants in the Omicron
Family as a rule
are less likely to penetrate deep into
your lungs and and lead to
life-threatening pneumonia they're more
likely to remain in the upper
respiratory tract some Studies have
shown that Omicron is a lot less
effective at infecting lung cells than
Delta and earlier variants of SARS cov2
were another off-sided belief among
Healthcare authorities is that by this
point in the pandemic
widespread previous exposure and or
vaccination are likely ramping up immune
defenses much faster when people are
freshly infected
and that helps keep their symptoms from
spiraling out of control
researchers so far aren't detecting any
major differences and the symptoms
caused by different Omicron subvariants
though they vary from Patient to Patient
of course
the list often includes having a runny
nose a sore throat fatigue headache and
sneezing so so ones that you dissociate
more with a bad cold or or bronchitis
doctors are also reporting that patients
are much less likely to complain of a
loss of smell and taste or or of
breathlessness which were frequent
symptoms caused by earlier variants
[Music]
foreign
next week among other things we'll look
at how Uganda managed to get the Ebola
outbreak under control until then
goodbye and take care
[Music]